with us now aren't with more on this as
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy everybody
in Washington has confirmed that's the
name being bantered about I can't
confirm unless you can confirm Paul
Sperrys reporting let's just stick to
the facts but you have heard this
person's name correct we won't mention
it yes but the only person who can
confirm this is Adam Schiff because he's
the individual who has met with him and
what's interesting remember what Adam
would say at the beginning like the
administration was going to hold this
whistleblower back then all this quid
pro quo was in there then once the call
came out and we saw the transcript where
the president has done nothing wrong
nothing to be impeached but now they
won't bring the whistleblower forward
what does Adam Schiff have to hide it
once again he's taken America through a
nightmare because of his lies what we
know is because we know there was
contact that's a fact
with ships office that would mean he's
compromised yeah that would mean he lied
yet again like he's lied for the last
three years how could anybody allow this
man to run any investigation he's exact
witness he is a fact witness and in in
our judicial system a fact witness
cannot be a prosecutor and what we'll
vote on tomorrow will not only key make
Adam Schiff a fact witness a prosecutor
a judge and a jury
he has stopped people witnesses from
answering questions so he objects but
then when he objects for them to answer
the question he's the judge who rules
whether they should answer the question
or not he should actually send these
witnesses a legal bill because he's also
their attorney and he's the only one
who's picking the witness nowhere in our
judicial system would we ever allow this
if this was in a court of law there
would be a mistrial right now based upon
what these Democrats have done and the
way they've treated this that all these
facts it is the fruit of the poisonous
tree this would all be thrown out but
only in Nancy's house do we write all
new laws and and you get no due process
lemaitre's we know the IG identified
this guy is political we know that
this isn't really this is a hearsay
whistleblower not even a whistleblower
we know that the Attorney General has
exonerated the president of any
wrongdoing but more importantly here's
what we also know we have the transcript
the transcript to mean not only
exonerates the president but it shows
the president because we know from a
Ukrainian court and political that in
fact they did interfere in our 2016
election I thought Democrats cared about
that we know the president was doing his
job
in other words faithfully executing the
laws we know that Joe Biden admits on
tape to a real quid pro quo either you
fire this guy or you're not getting the
billion dollars that would be a quid pro
quo we know hunter Biden had no
experience in Ukraine oil gas energy at
all but he got paid millions how do you
dismiss investigating that how do you
dismiss the compromise
Adam Schiff and the IG report saying
that non whistleblowers compromised you
know if you ask the American public
they want to see hunter actually
investigated because he got paid and
there was an action taken now all your
viewers have to understand what Adam
Schiff has lied to us about and why the
president has done nothing wrong they
had a phone call on July 25th the the
money was was sent on September 11th
Ukraine did nothing for the money to be
sent forward so there is no pro quo so
why are we carrying through this you
know why they continue to keep it in
Intel and not judiciary because Nadler
is a failure and shift is a fraud and is
willing to lie to the American public
they are taking a vote tomorrow you know
no Democrat should vote for that because
they're going to try to justify all the
actions he's already taken and they've
never even read one transcript you can
do as House Majority Leader what
Minority Leader but I'm sorry
House Minority Leader B assume be
Speaker hopefully me soon yes but but is
there anything you have in your arsenal
that you could do with your entire
caucus to make a statement and stop this
tomorrow
well you've watched
we've done time and again and we will
continue to fight every step of the way
but at the end of the day we live in a
rule of law and 2:18 is the rule of law
inside this floor what needs to really
happen is not just us but the American
people needs to join with us if you
believe that America is more than a
country then you have to have due
process pick up your phone now call
those Democrats and ask them what is the
impeachable offense why can you vote and
not have due process where Republicans
have given it to Democrat presidents and
Democrats have getit of two Republican
presidents why today is different why
are you putting this country through it
and worst of all we are now about one
year away from a new election and you
then the Democrats do not trust the
American people to make this decision
they think they are smarter than the
American people thank you we'll be
watching tomorrow